the killing of a policeman this week in
Paris by a suspected Islamist militant
may influence voters when they cast
ballots tomorrow in the first round of
the French presidential election French
authorities say the gunman was known to
law enforcement having spent 14 years in
prison he was shot and killed by police
during Thursday's attack a note
defending Isis was found near his body
Elizabeth Palmer is in the French
capital with the latest on an election
that is anything but predictable Liz
good morning good morning well it's a
very crowded field there are 11
candidates running in what is the most
hotly contested race in years it's no
secret that passions are running high
just look at the graffiti and as if
things weren't contentious enough while
officials were putting the finishing
touches to the electoral machine on
Thursday night a terrorist and convicted
criminal scrub in the heart of Paris
carries sherfy opened fire on a group of
police officers killing one and within
seconds sir fee to was dead John Finney
and his family from Kentucky or ten feet
away yo sprinting away from the bullets
the Finney's found refuge in a nearby
Sasquatch shop my boys start running my
wife starts running I get behind them
he's still shooting another round of
shots so I'm running like this trying to
block them okay as a shield because we
don't know where the shots are growing
on Friday they returned to thank the
manager who sheltered them in his
basement on the Shaw's easy near the
scene of the shooting it was business as
usual but the question is what impact
sure fees attack will have on France's
election Donald Trump predicted it would
help the far right candidate marine
lepen and certainly she used it
immediately to double down on promises
to close the borders and track down and
dangerous criminals as campaigning
officially drew to an end Parisians paid
their respects to the dead police
officer saviers you jealous and wondered
which if any of the candidates on
tomorrow's ballot can keep them
safe tomorrow's vote is going to whittle
those 11 candidates down to two
finalists who will go head-to-head in
the runoff on the 7th of May and at the
moment Alex the result is too close to
call Elizabeth Palmer in Paris thanks
Elizabeth